真正的好资产 根本就不是什么黄金啊 房子啊
只能算是资产吧
真正的好资产 其实我每个人都可以获得尤其在今天这个时代
但是很多人真的就把它糊塞掉了
你像我刚毕了那一会儿就做销售
就是给报师
那个廣告 做廣告 再先
就很多老婆就知道
然后呢 每天爱家爱户的
就是每天要走 我就从一个去走个另外一个去
每天被人拒绝
那就造牌呀
但是现在的话呢 我不做销售了
但我可能算是少有的好销售 就是我之前做的产品就做一款就基本上就可以賣得很好
做一款就可以賣得很好
你像我最近疫情的时间我就写得不输 就很多老婆就知道 你加上这些打这边输不输不输
就是哪里啊
我写完的时候 那天开支不 我都明白 我就跟那时候我的出小阿子就较得出窗里了
然后睡觉跟那聊天 一个小时第一次印刷 全部美国
好来我的
要变成一个发消息 说咱们可以用手
然后跟老婆就说 用手就把东西挂到了 结果呢
有直播下播了 俩有时候 就是总个直播两个小时嘛 然后第二次印刷
就也已经买卖光了 为什么呢
就是这是我跟大家分享了一个非常重要的资产
就是原门对你的信任 你的影响力 你用一些信任你的用户
朋友
这是我一直跟大家讲不说的 叫提前准备好你的用户
就是你的产品还没出来 但是你得用户应准备好了 我记得开了四月福特说过这么有话说
那些所谓的一首家 他们之所以有钱不是因为他们的作品有多好 而是因为他们有粉丝
那我是
能够特别深刻理解到这句话的 只要我有好想听 那我就可以卖的 卖得很好 那很多人说
那是因为你有用户的话 再过我们就很难用很难获得 事实上用户是非常容易获得的
你也不需要有什么样的文品 我发现很多人对文品这个事很职责
就很多老伙议都知道了 我就中了什么 我在写说的 说过了 对了 我在
我在书里面 一开始就说得特别清楚 我这个中的认识
对了
然后呢
我真正开始学习是参加工作以后 言格的说是我做销售
二的没有办事以后 然后我才开始 我才开始学习的 那么
有的时候不是说你的文并比我多好 就是你是真的能够帮助别人 把你的知识 把你的经验呀
很真正的分享给大家 那你是养猪的 你就告诉大家 我是怎么养猪的
对吧 我是重地的 我告诉大家 我是第一次这么重的 我的出 我是做饭的 我出师 对吧 然后我就告诉大家 我这个胡烧肉是怎么做的
就不是说你的文并有多好 有很转的物务去文并要非常好 其实不是你的文并有多好 不是你多能说
而是你分享那个知识那个经验 真的对别人有帮助 能帮助到大家
别人能够看清楚这件事情 那其实就 能不能就会就会训认你 对吧
但是你要把话说清楚 这个还是还是去练练习的 你就像这本说来说 我在写的工作 其实我没有想到这个文并有多好
就是我就是把一件事情说清楚 说不过我是中专B了之后
我遇到什么问题 然后我是怎么刺血的 对吧 开始就不得还敢学义的发表 我重新学习 怎么学习 怎么越多 怎么思考
怎么办 怎么办 怎么办 怎么办 怎么办 学到知识用出来的
就是我跟大家分享的东西 包括我后来的话 怎么开始做事 怎么开公司
我的第一统计是是什么做的 包括我怎么投积 怎么做投积
年快说 这几个方面 我都不得做最好的 学习我这些的最好的吗 都要在没考上北打清话 我说是 开公司我这做最好的吗 其实也没有啊 对吧
但是我就生怀上可以的 投积都是做最好吗 其实也不是 但是我很真成的
把我的一些想法了 我的一些经验 我的过往 就分享给大家 那对大家真的有帮助
那么人们自然而然就会喜欢 你就会获得信任 你自然就会获得这个实际上最棒的自餐 就是人们对得信任的影响
让你一些信任你的喜欢你的用户 对吧 这一个好方便 假好用户 当于满力
如果我作为一个中卷场合道 那我觉得你应该也能做到